dans les locaux de l'opérateur
téléphonique de lille une pièce pas
comme les autres on l'appelle la war
room ou caisse de guerre les mieux de
rassembler dans une même pièce
l'ensemble des personnes qui vont
intervenir sur le projet pour avoir pour
prendre des décisions très rapidement et
pouvoir également garder une certaine
confidentialité quant à la nature des
problèmes plus de confidentialité pour
des projets sensibles
de toute façon un visiteur un peu trop
curieux aurait bien du mal à comprendre
ce qui se dit ici les gars de talent
durée facteur de la table ping on essaie
de voir comment on peut attaquer ça huit
français en deux et faire le con
services spécialisés dans la
récupération des des informations sur
les équipements basse tous sont
ingénieurs et parmi eux yannick 34 ans
et christophe 32 ans après avoir
travaillé pour de grandes entreprises
françaises et même le ministère de
l'intérieur
le jeune homme a choisi de rentrer en
martinique c'est compliqué de trouver un
emploi aussi qualifié avec autant
d'ambition technologique sur mon secteur
d'activité
maintenant c'est possible donc j'ai
réussi à le faire
la jeune équipe a développé une
application innovante pour un opérateur
téléphonique à bas prix elle permet à
l'utilisateur de commander une carte sim
sans se déplacer et de choisir au
forfait sur mesure
ici on va choisir donc de commander une
nouvelle carte sim et là on choisit son
enfant fait donc ça c'est une des
grandes innovations de weezy c'est qu'on
peut configurer son forfait à sa guise
donc si je veux un 10 50 gigas de data
avec les appels illimités mais entendu
les sms illimités mais ça fait 10 euros
par mois
mais si j'ai besoin de plus de giga
j'aurais pu monter jusqu'à 70 par
exemple on a la possibilité de choisir
son numéro l'utilisateur scanne ensuite
pièce d'identité et carte bancaire
il recevra sa carte sim par la poste
yannick est en charge de la partie
marketing
lui aussi a fait ses études dans
l'hexagone ayez a débuté sa carrière
professionnelle il n'a pas hésité à
rejoindre son île natale
je pense qu'on en oublie assez souvent
qu'on est déjà une terre d'opportunités
il ya plein de choses à développer ici
alors que beaucoup de choses sont déjà
fait ailleurs et effectivement de
revenir avec ses compétences est arrivé
sur des projets nouveaux novateur qui
qui qui sont très motivants pour le coup
c'est c'est une grande fierté finalement
malgré des exemples comme ceux de
christophe et yannick chaque année en
moyenne 3300 habitants quittent la
martinique principalement des jeunes en
poursuite d'études ou en quête d'emploi